welcome to the apogee upclose webcast
we do these twice a month the topics are
based on popular demand you can sign up
multiple times
and you can ask questions live hi i'm
keith daneken i'm a customer engineer
with abigail part of google cloud
platform
today we're going to look at the top 10
tips to help you have a better api
program
in the new year so if you're going to
put together a checklist of things you
should do to make sure you have a
successful api program in 2019
what will be on your list i've been
talking with my colleagues at apogee
about their suggestions and i put
together a list of the top 10
suggestions
they fell roughly under three categories
process tips
product tips and infrastructure and
devops tips
so let's get started i'm going to start
with four topics on improving your
process
so number one think outside in if you've
attended an apigee webcast before you've
probably seen this
it's core to how we think about how api
management should work
it's worth taking another look in the
context of this webcast
we've seen a repeated pattern of success
with our customers and
it's driven by how they think about the
api problem it requires a shift in
thinking
traditionally we think about services
from an exposure point of view
we can just expose a service and be
finished but
thinking about it from the end user's
point of view leads to better results
our successful customers start with the
user thinking about what that user's
experience will be like and working
backwards from there
providing application developers with
great apis reduces the complexity of
creating new applications
the developer's free to focus on user
experience and iterate on a few
different designs
the api team makes this possible by
providing an easy to use api with
consistent interfaces and security
the api team builds the api facades on
the existing services
abstracting away the complexity this
makes it easy
to build great apis that are easy to use
so keep this pattern in mind when you
build your apis tip number two
develop an api product mindset so apis
are not one-off products
but products that need continuous
iteration and development so
focus on that life cycle so what does it
mean to productize an api
there's many aspects we might talk about
but we find it helpful to focus on these
three items
outside in speed to market and iterative
delivery
might help to look at an example let's
look at how walgreens talks about their
api products they've got a bunch of
different api
products and they're split into all
these different categories that you see
on the slide here
this is very deliberate in terms of how
they package these and how they manage
them and things like that so walgreens
says that their api products are managed
like any other product within their
digital product portfolio
there are a few keys to success for what
that looks like
they have a product roadmap for apis and
presented quarterly to their entire
digital product team
partners business teams marketing and
other key stakeholders
so there is great visibility into what
they're doing and it's a great source of
opportunity and partnership with
other teams second thing they have a
fantastic developer evangelist and he
actually sits within the product team
so the partnership with the product
managers is very strong next they have
great tools to engage with their
developer community and manage their api
program
they have a developer portal which is
the initial entry point to their apis
and of course they have apogee which
allows them to be a great partner to
their developer community
and last but definitely not least they
put a big focus as with any other
product on defining what success looks
like
and reporting out their performance
against those metrics so another tip is
to create an api product manager role
that's somebody who's going to manage
apis across the entire lifecycle
they're going to take that vision and
turn into action and their subject
matter expert so tip number three
focus on the application developer so
why are api developers
so important api consumer adoption is
key to success for any api program apis
will need to be marketed
to api consumers as products not just as
raw services
application developers are your ultimate
consumers
so keep them in mind when you're
developing your api program you may have
different types of application
developers
who will have different requirements for
your apis for example you might have
internal application developers partners
application developers and external
application developers
all building different things all with
different wants and needs when it comes
to your api program
shutter stock is creating a great
developer experience by answering the
most important questions that arise
during development
and creating a great getting started in
onboarding experience
so imagine that you're an api consumer
you're an application developer and you
go to their website
this is this is great it's got
everything you need to get started and
they reduce the amount of friction
encouraging people to develop things so
tip number four pick an mvbo
where do you start with your api project
using an mvbo
is a great place to start so what is an
mvbl
an mvbo is a minimum viable business
outcome
it's a small yet business critical
delivery that showcases the opportunity
and starts building ongoing delivery
momentum
so how do you pick a good mvbo the mvbo
should focus on creating milestones for
business
enablement and pave the path for others
to follow it and the mvbo
should be ready it should be engaging
and it should be sufficiently difficult
let's look at each of those in a bit
more detail so ready means that
the project you pick can get into
production quickly and demonstrate value
speed's going to be essential here so
that means you should avoid complex
program or delivery dependencies
avoid target backend systems that
require significant refactoring
avoid use cases where the user base or
customer demand does not already exist
it should be engaging so make sure your
project is engaging
you need to deliver something of clear
business value and impact aligned to
strategic goals and sponsor interest
it should be it should deliver strategic
value deliver business value
it should resonate with your audience
and it should create a pathway for
repeatable success
your mvbo should be sufficiently
difficult the apis delivered should not
just be pass-throughs they should be
complex enough
to demonstrate key api management
benefits including
controlled access to resources and
assets analytics
self-service consumption by a developer
portal
and they should demonstrate how they'll
scale so consider all those things when
you're thinking about an mvbo
next let's look at three tips in the
product category
tip number five standardize the security
backend services often have different
protocols for authentication
depending on when they were developed
navigating those multiple security
protocols causes extra work for api
consumers
consider standardizing the security you
present to your api consumers they'll be
much happier and they'll thank you for
this
an api platform can help you standardize
your security in addition to policies
for authentication
there's policies for rate limiting and
quotas payload protection and more
your api platform can control access to
protected resources
to help you with compliance also you may
need to tie into an existing identity
management system this is an example of
a flow that
generates an oauth token after users
enter their passwords
the authentication flow makes a call out
to the identity system to verify the
user's username and password
and if the credentials are accepted it
returns a token to the application that
is then sent to the business flow
so simple example of how you might
integrate with an existing
identity management system number six
measure monitor and improve so how do
you improve your api program
measuring how applications call it and
monitoring the performance will help you
know
what needs to be tuned and give you data
on how your program is doing
so after you've built a few apis and
your application developers have
discovered them
and started to send you traffic be great
if you could measure your api program
the analytics system in apigee edge
allows you to measure every aspect of
your api traffic you can measure
operational details like response time
frequency of different types of errors
you can find things that are interesting
to your business
like where are people located when they
call your apis or which applications are
sending the most traffic
maybe it's interesting to see what type
of client they're using are they on
internet explorer are they on chrome are
they on different mobile platforms
all of these things can be answered with
analytics reports
so what should you be measuring here's a
list of some of the common metrics that
we've heard from customers that they
find valuable
so think about the number of apis the
number of developers the number of
customers
number of partners the number of apps
the speed to api
speed to onboard so in other words how
long does it take to get up and going
traffic growth business breadth cost
reduction direct revenue
and net promoter score apogee has some
great reports to help you understand
your api program for example
here is an engagement report that shows
you how many developers are using your
platform and their level of engagement
so one final important aspect of
operating an api platform is ensuring
the availability of your apis
apigee launched apr monitoring product a
couple weeks ago
freely available now to all cloud-based
enterprise edge customers
by the apis and the applications that
use them make sure your apis deliver
value either directly or indirectly
consider measuring your rate of
innovation or your time to app
while an api may not directly generate
revenue what value
does it bring if you can create
applications in a month instead of a
year
can apis provide you with new sources of
value do you have unique data
that might be valuable to others can you
charge for it what new channels of
business
can you explore accuweather is able to
monetize their data by packaging it into
different offerings with different price
points
so think of approaches for how you might
want to do this
next let's shift to infrastructure and
devops i have four tips in this category
tip number eight automate and integrate
the ui is great but
automation is even better most users
start off with the ui
but they'll move to automating parts of
their processes apogee has a great set
of management apis that allow you to
automate every aspect of the platform
take a look at the reference docs and
start exploring these i've got the url
on the screen here
the apigee community is a great place to
find advice and resources for ci cd
automation there's a lot of people
who've gone through this before you
and there's links to tools and
discussion of how to use them
number nine grow with microservices
microservices enable developers to build
and deploy software with speed agility
and scale necessary to meet the needs of
your business
you can decompose a monolithic
application into a set of services that
can be developed
and released independently
microservices are an architecture
approach to software development where
software is composed of small
independent services that communicate
over well-defined apis
microservices enable modern enterprises
to create a flexible architecture where
services can be versioned deployed
and scaled without impact to other
systems or applications
so the great thing about microservices
is they can easily grow with your
business
but that comes with some new
complexities an app development team
may rush to implement microservices and
when they do this they inadvertently
create silos with inconsistencies in
security visibility documentation and
governance
many of the apis that connect
microservices are not secured
consistently across the organization
so these microservices and associate
apis are often difficult to reuse
analyze or even discover for use by
their teams you can solve this problem
by managing the consumption of your
microservices
with your api platform so number 10
let's talk about cloud migration
migrating to the cloud isn't
a straight path enterprises adopt
different paths to define their cloud
strategy often enterprises will pick
multiple paths based on different
projects or workloads
so there's three key takeaways from this
slide migration paths will vary
even within the company and across
applications migration
migrations are not instant some take
months or even years
across all the paths of migration api
management can play a key role
in making integrations easier so how can
api management help
so a few different things to look at
here apogee can help with many of these
different challenges
service connectivity one of the primary
concerns of app migration is tight
coupling of the clients or user
experiences to the backend services or
apps
apogee acts as an abstraction layer
between the exposure and consumption
allowing for service connectivity
while parts of the app's back end or
front end are migrated
to the cloud security enforcement apigee
can act both as a security enforcement
layer as well as a security mediation
layer
as apps are modernized while moving to
the cloud it's very common
for the modern apps to have a different
security mechanism like jwt or oauth
versus the legacy traditional back ends
like saml basic auth etc apogee can
bring in uniformity by allowing the
modern apps
to use one common mechanism while
mediating the credentials while talking
to the legacy back-ends and vice versa
apigee can also make sure that security
mechanisms like regex checks
dlp enforcement are done while on-prem
apps
that have strict compliance needs are
calling
the cloud workloads for visibility
by acting as the facade across on-prem
gcp workloads apigee can provide
visibility into how app migrations are
happening
and the success or traction for the
migrated apps the api metrics that
apigee provides are slightly higher
level as apigee will have visibility
into which apps developer
clients are calling your api which api
product is being used to call the api
and etc
the api metrics can be pulled in through
apogee's management api and analyzed
along with other operational metrics
collected by by the app's logging
framework etc
api facades so most often not all of the
apps can be migrated at once
the re-platformed or modernized apps
will have to talk to a monolith or
legacy
or traditional backend these back-ends
most of the times will be in legacy
protocols like soap
xml it's not ideal for modern apps to
consume them that way and it adds the
additional burden of maintaining
additional libraries making the app
heavier and complex
apigee can help create api facades that
are modern while keeping the monolith
intact
the re-platformed or modern apps can
talk to these facades instead of going
directly to the back end
and finally service management lift and
modernization is one of the standard
themes of app migration
microservices often on kubernetes is a
vehicle for app modernization as
enterprises realize the success of
microservices-based architectures
the number of microservices explodes and
the apps are migrated to cloud
without the right security and
visibility it's extremely difficult to
accelerate the adoption of microservices
some enterprises are already already
looking at istio to solve this problem
for customers who have adopted istio
apogee can provide
enterprise support for non-gcp istio
implementations as well as add the
higher level
api management aspects like oauth
through the mixer adapter
for customers who are not looking at sdl
example customers
who are on pcf apogee's microgateway can
add similar capabilities
and manage their microservices like
security and analytics
so that's the top ten list next up let's
take some questions
okay let's start off with the first
question where should i start with the
management apis
how can they be used to automate my
deployment so
take a look at the reference section of
the api documentation
for apigee and in there you'll see a
list of all of those
pick one or two and play with it and
just get a feel for how it works
one thing people will commonly do is
automate the deployment process
so meaning if you're going to push
something for example from
dev to test or from maybe tests or qa
into production
you can automate that so take a look at
the the management api specifically
around that area
and give that a try next question has to
deal with
analytics and measuring your apis and
the question there is
how can i measure something business
specific with a custom report in apigee
so there's a statistics collector policy
in there the statistics collector policy
lets you grab anything
that's a variable in apogee so anything
from the request to the response or
anything you want to extract out of
there
you can save that as a custom metric and
that can be used in the reporting system
so you can combine that with the
built-in analytics build a custom report
and measure something that's interesting
so
think about what you might what you
might want to measure with that
okay next question you touched on
experience apis
what is an experience api so think of an
experience
as a an application or how somebody
would
experience your your services
so a lot of times we'll build custom
services just for
a particular application like you might
have a an experience api
to support a mobile application and
what's nice about having an api platform
for this is it lets you
easily build a custom api that's
specific to the experience that you're
trying to share
so next one in here is a question about
getting started with using apis for
consuming microservices
so what are the best practices and how
do you get started with this
so i'm going to go back to that outside
in type of thinking
so think about how we want to control
how people experience these
microservices
a great place to put apogee is right on
top of those microservices and it would
be used to
control access for external consumers
so put apogee in there and treat the
back end like you would any other back
end only it's going to be microservices
in this case
so what about measuring the number of
active subscriptions
uh that's a great idea so that is a good
metric to
to measure so you could do that through
some of the built-in reports that are uh
that are in apogee there's particularly
there's a developer engagement one
that'll show you who's subscribed and
what they're doing and things like that
there's a question in here uh where the
the listener
missed some bits of authentication
what's the best way to integrate with
vendors like octa
sso for oauth or abstract from end users
so there's a great webcast out there
that you may have seen last year take a
look out on
the youtube channel for apogee i've got
another webcast out there that just
deals with that topic
so basically there are policies inside
of apogee that will generate
oauth tokens and what you'll do is the
generation of that token
if you just put that in your flow it's
just going to generate a token
typically what people will do is they're
going to put some logic in front of that
to generate or not to generate to call
out to the identity management system
and verify the user in some way and then
if and only if they're good
will they generate the token so that's
the general pattern in there but there's
a whole webcast on that take a look on
the youtube channel
and you'll see under the apogee up close
series
there is a webcast just covering that
topic there's a question in here
transitioning to the api world is
disruptive to existing internal dev
community
what tips can you give for elevating
internal dev community learning
how best to promote and encourage so i
would explore
um why is it disruptive to move to the
to the api world and what is it about
that
um some of the things we'd focus on is
what's the onboarding process for apis
so is it easier if you have
an api management platform in place is
there a developer portal where they can
go and find examples and things like
that
so it it should be something the
developers are excited about and it
should be something that can be done
in a way that it's not too disruptive so
explore where the friction is in there
and work on that
so what best describes the attributes of
an api or a digital team
so we'll rephrase this as as kind of
who's on that team or
what they're doing so when you're first
getting started this might be a smaller
team there might be people on there who
are going to be
building apis and those might be people
who build web services in the past or at
least they have a knowledge of what the
back end services are
and and can look at those and figure out
what to expose
over time we'd like to add an api
product manager
because we want to think about these
things as products manage their
lifecycle and things like that so that's
going to be somebody who's a little bit
more business focused you may have some
people on there who are viewing reports
and measuring things uh there they'd
probably fall under that
that product manager role also you may
have some
people in there who are going to be
consuming these apis
but the team varies quite a bit um
you'll find a lot of different people on
the api team
there's a question here for enterprises
with b2b partners can apigee play an
outbound api
call management role management of calls
originating from originating from
inside so yeah we do see this so the
pattern here is that you can manage any
kind of api call so
maybe you're calling out or maybe you're
receiving calls coming in
either way you can think of this as a
good place to have api management if you
want to be able to measure that traffic
if you want to be able to
control it reshape requests and things
like that
you can use it for inside calls or for
outside calls and whether you're calling
in or out
question here is is there such a thing
as a private internal api
if yes how is it treated differently so
uh
private or internal api i might think of
that as an experience api and
and really the only thing that's going
to make it private versus public
is how you choose to expose it and um
you know who has access to it and and
who can use it
but we see this commonly we'll see
people have uh completely
uh you know big internal api programs at
their companies
where they're they're developing all
these things and none of it's exposed
externally
so yeah that's a very common use case
next question can apigee support custom
transformations also
does apogee support api orchestration so
for custom transformations yes very much
so so we have built-in
transformations in there for json to xml
xml to json
you can also use xslt in there if you're
working with xml
and there's support for using different
languages in there for custom policies
so
java javascript and python can be used
and they have complete control over the
request and the response flow so one
thing that's very common is
you might write a little bit of
javascript or java code in there and
that would
transform the response that comes back
that's that's a common use case
on the second side of that can apogee
support api orchestration
yes that's a common use case so you're
going to have one call in and then you
might call two or three different
services on the back end
collect those responses and orchestrate
them so yeah you can do that
there's direct callouts to do that if
you want to do it synchronously if you
want to do it asynchronously
you can do it with some of the built-in
programming languages for the custom
policies
the question here is a response to the
other one thank you for clarifying on
experience apis
how does it work with api facades do
they complement or supplement each other
so an experience api is really something
that's custom built to
support a particular application a
facade i would describe
as what you're doing is you're hiding
away the complexities of the enterprise
so you're separating the external
interface from the internal
implementation of that api
so think about how would you ideally
like to have this api look to the
outside world
and build an interface that looks like
that and then map that to the internal
services
and that can be done in a number of
different ways but really the difference
between these two
is the intention are we building this
for a specific
use or is this just a general purpose
way to improve
and simplify how our api is to call how
do you demonstrate the value of api
driven architecture within an enterprise
if they're happy with an esb
led architecture yeah that's a tough one
so
i would say once they get to see
something like this uh they would
absolutely love it
uh you know if i'm thinking old school
esp style architecture
uh where this would be better is think
about um
how long does it take you to develop an
application so if you wanted to write a
new
single page web application or a new
mobile application
what's that process like and how long
does it take to do something like that
also where's the documentation is there
a developer portal today that has
everything somebody would be on there
what's the process
for a developer to onboard so those are
a few things to look at that might help
with that
can you map existing microservices to
apigee how can you achieve that
so yeah you sure can so think about it
like
the back end is going to be a set of
microservices so you're going to build
a facade on top of that build a proxy in
apogee
and that will talk to those various
back-end systems okay a few more
questions coming in
what's my opinion on api versioning
putting the version at the level of the
path or
the content so this is uh this is one of
those things that's very contentious in
the in the api world
how do you do versioning i've seen many
different ways to do this
the most common i have seen and the
advice that we tend to give is
put the version in the url so um
and keep it as far to the left as
possible so that's that's the
um most common we see i've seen it done
in headers though
uh i've seen it done in a number of
different ways but that's the most
common that i'm saying
does apogee istio replace existing
middleware integration and adapter
technologies
istio would help you manage a set of
microservices
sometimes those microservices might be
replacing internal
technologies sometimes they might be
supplementing them i've seen a lot of
folks do micro services for new projects
and they would be complementary or
supplemental to existing things that are
in place
okay i'm going to take a few more
questions uh and then we'll move on to a
poll
thank you for all the questions i've got
a lot of them in here there's a question
in here is there a way to onboard an api
developer manually
currently uh the developer subscription
is done automatically i have a use case
where i want to do some verification
before granting the subscription is this
possible
so yes it is you can check in apogee
you can set up that it's going to be
done manually and then you can go into
the
dashboard where you approve apps and you
would have to approve it in there
it can also be done through an api okay
i'll take
two more and then we'll wrap up can
apogee leverage cloud functions
or use a cloud function as the back-end
api source can it use pub sub for
queuing
so yes absolutely so a few different
ways to do this
um we've got some um we've got some
connectors that are
in apogee for google cloud platform so
if you're working on google cloud
platform you'll find built-in support
for this
if you happen to be working on aws or
another cloud
check our documentation for that there
are some examples of doing
lambda functions or um in other cases
as long as something has an api or
that can be connected to through http
this is going to be pretty easy to do
what's the preferred approach to
restrict access to apis protected by
apogee so traffic must go through apogee
first
firewall rules tls certificates um how
do we do that
so yes firewall rules and tls
certificates uh
would be two ways to do that but
basically
some form of cutting off access that
doesn't go through apogee and that's
typically done through
through networking techniques all right
our next webcast coming up on january
17th
is hybrid apps migration and
modernization and the need for api
management
thank you for attending today and happy
new year to everyone out there from
everyone at apogee
you